et toujours parlons un mode samedi
dernier le centre juan les chaînes
pareille aux clayes-sous-bois proposé
quatre défilés d'articles de mode à prix
réduit la structure présenter des
collections homme femme et enfant
printemps-été 2016 mettant en avant les
commerces qu'elle accueille
elodie gossuin grandes stars mannequin
et miss france 2001 présentait les
défilés pour le plus grand bonheur de
pousser côté je ne peux pas le prendre
pour moi je pense je le prends plutôt
par rapport à l'événement dans sa
globalité voilà ça fait partie de tels
événements des défilés de la danse
voilà deux
c'est de créer quelque chose qui
transmettent une petite part de magie
effectivement je pense que ça peut nous
faire que du bien et à tout un chacun
voilà c'est aussi de rêver de partager
et puis deux
de montrer aussi ce que l'on sait faire
et localement et de donner envie de le
partager avec les gens